.
Ich will zu dir nach Hause.
Ich habe Angst,
dass ich alles verlieren werde.
Nein, du wirst uns nie verlieren.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Die Frau, die ich meiner Mutter
vorstelle, werde ich heiraten.
Ich suchte nicht kopflos
nach dem Vater meiner Kinder.
Darf ich sagen,
dass du mich gefragt hast,
ob ich zu dir nach Hause komme?
Okay, das ist dir zu peinlich.
Eher etwas intim.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
# Forever you and me.
* Popsong: "Take My Hand" von
Adrian Stern und Martin Villiger *
* Fröhliche Gitarrenklänge *
Modena, Norditalien.
Seit fünf Jahren das Zuhause
von Simona Borner und ihrer Familie.
Ian, hallo.
Zu Hause reden sie Spanisch
und Schweizerdeutsch,
im Kindergarten
lernt Sohn Ian Italienisch.
Ist es gut gegangen?
- Bestens. Er war auch draussen.
Gut, danke. Bis morgen, tschüss!
War es gut in der Schule?
Hat er sich versteckt?
Ian! Wo ist er?
Sie hätte nie gedacht, dass sie mit
ihrer Familie im Ausland leben würde.
Aber dann verliebte sie sich.
Mit Juan
kamen die Autos in ihr Leben.
Ihr Mann Juan,
Maschineningenieur aus Spanien,
hat bei Ferrari
seinen Traumjob gefunden.
* Ella jammert. *
Traumjob hin oder her -
im Homeoffice
muss sich auch ein Ferrari-Ingenieur
der Familie anpassen.
Normalerweise arbeite ich
im kleinen Nebenzimmer,
aber wenn die Kinder zu laut sind,
ziehe ich mich hierhin zurück.
Da kann ich zwei Türen
hinter mir schliessen.
Es ist ruhiger.
Juan entwickelt mit seinem Team
Motoren für Formel-1-Boliden.
Er ist daran gewöhnt,
hochpräzise zu arbeiten.
Im Umgang mit der Zeit
nimmt er es etwas lockerer.
Wenn er sagt:
"Ich komme in einer halben Stunde",
muss man immer 20 Min. dazurechnen.
Diese Regel könnte man
schwarz auf weiss aufschreiben.
Zeitmanagement geht anders.
Ich bin selten zu spät.
Aber er ist selten zu spät.
Ich kenne sehr viele Schweizer,
die auch zu spät kommen.
Er findet halt,
und da hat er auch recht ...
Er versucht
mir seit zehn Jahren zu sagen,
dass ich nicht nervös werden muss,
wenn er zu spät kommt.
Das ist so tief verankert,
das kann man fast nicht verändern.
Mmh.
- Mmh.
Du musst Mama helfen.
Bevor die Kinder kamen,
führten Simona und Juan
fünf Jahre eine Fernbeziehung.
Er war in Paris,
sie in Olten zu Hause.
Als wir hierherzogen, lebten wir
zum ersten Mal überhaupt zusammen.
Klar mussten wir schauen,
wie das Zusammenleben funktioniert.
Aber v.a. für mich war schon klar:
Ich möchte schnell mal ...
... eine Familie planen,
Kinder haben.
Eine Familie wollten beide.
Simona gab dafür die Heimat,
den Job und die Karriere auf.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenklänge *
Du warst als Ergotherapeutin
voll im Beruf.
Du warst selbständig
und hattest dein Leben dort.
Du bist wegen ihm hierhergezogen
und hast alles zurückgelassen.
Das ist auch ein Ungleichgewicht.
Ist das manchmal schwierig
für die Beziehung?
Er sieht das Ungleichgewicht
nicht so.
Ich sah das lange so.
Am Anfang habe ich es ihm unter
die Nase gerieben und vorgeworfen
Wenn man Diskussionen
oder Unstimmigkeiten hat,
kommt die Frustration und Wut
wieder vor:
"Ich bin wegen dir hierhergezogen
und habe alles zurückgelassen."
Er kommt aus Spanien,
er ist eher ein Muttersöhnchen,
die Spanier
werden von ihren Müttern verwöhnt.
Das geht dann so weiter.
Und wenn wir das mal so leben,
ist es ...
... eingespurt ...
... ist es für immer eingespurt.
Ich habe gesagt, dass du
ein Muttersöhnchen bist, sorry!
Kein Problem.
Ich dachte,
wenn ich einen Kompromiss mache,
dann muss er den nächsten machen,
der ist dann vielleicht die Schweiz.
Ich habe das immer
etwas neckisch kommuniziert:
"Ich mache das jetzt,
aber der nächste bist du."
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Wer steht zurück,
wer verzichtet zugunsten des anderen?
Das richtige Gleichgewicht zu finden,
ist für jede Beziehung essentiell.
In binationalen sind solche Ent-
scheidungen besonders einschneidend.
Wenn Simona etwas will,
dann kämpft sie dafür.
Sie hat eine starke Persönlichkeit.
Das ist gut.
Für Ferrari zu arbeiten
ist ein Traum für mich.
Eine Chance,
die ich einfach ergreifen musste.
* Gemütliche Gitarrenklänge *
* Herzschlag *
Was noch passiert ist?
Ich habe ihm betrunken im Taxi
von meinen schlechten Erfahrungen
mit Amerikanern erzählt.
Ich habe ihn gewarnt:
"Komm nicht auf dumme Gedanken."
Ich verbrachte die Nacht hier.
Vielleicht war es naiv,
aber es fühlte sich richtig an.
Es klingt blöd, aber
es war Liebe auf den ersten Blick.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Die Liebe blieb.
Magners, I know. Come on, let's go.
Und Corgi Magners kam dazu.
Come on.
Noëlle aus dem Glarnerland
und Kalifornier Matt
sind seit sieben Jahren ein Paar.
Nimm das.
Prost.
Noëlle ist nicht
die einzige aus ihrer Familie,
die das Glarnerland
wegen eines Mannes verlassen hat.
Ihre Schwester Fabienne
verschlug die Liebe nach Hawaii,
gut fünf Flugstunden westlicher.
Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass ich
so schöne Muscheln finden würde.
Lucky!
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Noëlle ging nach Amerika
eher in die Ferien.
Ich auch,
aber ich reiste noch an andere Orte,
nicht nur nach Amerika.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie sie darüber denkt,
wir sagten uns nicht,
dass wir nach Amerika ziehen müssen.
Das ist einfach passiert.
Ich glaube, sie hat mehr Heimweh
nach dem Glarnerland als ich.
Aber wir sind wenigstens
in der gleichen Flugrichtung.
Wenn nur dieses verflixte Heimweh
nicht wäre.
Trotz Liebe und Glück:
Noëlle vermisst ihre Familie
und die vertraute Umgebung.
Corona und der Shutdown
machen es noch schwerer.
Rausgehen und Freunde treffen
geht nicht mehr.
Wegen der Reisebeschränkungen
musste ihre Mutter den Besuch
in San Francisco absagen.
Über ein Jahr hat Noëlle ihre Familie
schon nicht mehr gesehen.
Es war das erste Mal,
dass Noëlle ihre Familie in der
Schweiz so lange nicht sehen konnte.
Das hat ihr sehr zugesetzt.
Ich sagte ihr,
wenn deine Schule einwilligt,
von der Schweiz aus zu arbeiten,
dann buch ein Ticket und flieg heim.
Und genau das hat Noëlle gemacht.
Weder meine Mama noch mein Papa noch
meine Freude wissen, dass ich komme,
dass ich in der Schweiz bin,
ich realisiere es noch nicht.
(Durchsage) Netstal.
Geil!
Das findet man
auch nur in der Schweiz.
Eine Blindschliche.
Die haben wir als Kinder
immer gesucht.
Ich lass dich runter.
Um ihre Mutter zu überraschen,
hat sie eine Freundin eingeweiht,
die Noëlles ahnungslose Mutter
heute zum Kaffee eingeladen hat.
Ich schaue mal nach.
Mich darf sie ja sehen
auf dem Balkon.
Oh Gott, da ist sie.
Ich lasse die Türe offen.
- Ja.
* Türklingel *
Ja?
Saluti.
Du bist hübsch.
Das ist gut.
- Wirklich? Hoi.
Hey super, das ist gut.
Sie sagte,
ich müsse dir Bescheid geben.
Meili, oder nicht?
Oh, nein, komm her.
Oh, nein, was machst du hier?
Prost zusammen.
Nein.
Dass gleich beide Töchter innerhalb
eines halben Jahres auswanderten,
war für Susanne Kaiser nicht einfach.
Solche Spässe mit mir machen
mit bald 60.
Das kannst du nicht machen.
Als ich das erste Mal zurückkam,
nachdem ich dort war,
war es ganz schlimm für mich.
Daran kann ich mich erinnern.
Ich kam nach Hause und fühlte mich
total verloren meinem Haus.
Es war auch intensiv,
weil ich geschieden bin
und wir zusammengelebt haben.
Wir wohnten zusammen
in einer Frauen-WG.
Aber ich mag es ihnen gönnen,
dass sie ihrer Liebe folgen konnten,
und v.a. versuchen,
dass sie so das Leben
des anderen kennenzulernen.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Wenn Mama Freunden erzählt,
dass wir beide nach Amerika gehen,
fragen alle: "Wieso?"
"Du Arme."
Das spricht sich im Glarnerland
schnell herum.
In Honolulu ist Francis
schon früh auf den Beinen.
Lunch einpacken.
Mit Hawaii-Bildern wie Surfen und
Tourismus hat Francis nichts am Hut.
Er arbeitet an einem Ort, der Hawaii
in einem ganz anderen Zusammenhang
zu weltweiter Bekanntheit verhalf.
Francis ist Monteur auf der
Militärbasis von Pearl Harbour.
Gleich nach der Highschool
ging ich zur Armee.
Ich hatte keine
klaren beruflichen Vorstellungen.
Die Armee ist ein guter Start.
V.a. bieten sie
Stipendien fürs College an.
Man sammelt Lebenserfahrung und
lernt verschiedene Länder kennen.
Reisen und Länder entdecken hiess
für Francis, in den Krieg zu ziehen.
Als ich im Militär war,
wurde ich 2009/2010
nach Afghanistan geschickt.
Es war
eine beängstigende Zeit für mich,
ich wusste nicht,
ob ich überleben werde.
Aber es machte mich auch
zu einem besseren Menschen.
Ich wurde stärker und begann,
an mich zu glauben.
Ich lernte darauf zu vertrauen,
dass es
einen nächsten Tag geben wird.
In Pearl Harbour
habe ich eine stabile Arbeit.
Ich kann für mich und Fabienne
aufkommen.
Und später auch für eine Familie.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Jung die Welt zu entdecken,
war für Fabienne viel unbelasteter.
Hi, Gryf.
Vor ein paar Jahren machte sie
in Hawaii einen Sprachaufenthalt.
Als sie später noch mal
auf die Insel in die Ferien kam,
lernte sie Francis kennen.
* Piepsen *
You're good.
Hi.
* Piepsen *
Sie arbeitet in Honolulu
in der gleichen Sprachschule,
die sie auch besuchte.
Ich freue mich,
wenn die Schüler glücklich sind,
sie hier eine gute Zeit verbringen
und am Schluss traurig sind,
wenn sie nach Hause müssen.
Dann haben wir es richtig gemacht.
Auch, wenn sie Tipps brauchen, die
man eben nicht im Internet findet.
Ihnen helfen.
Dank der schnellen Heirat mit Francis
bekam Fabienne nach gut acht Monaten
eine Arbeitsbewilligung.
How are you?
- Fine.
* Piepsen *
You're good, thank you.
Auf die Greencard,
das unbeschränkte Aufenthaltsrecht,
wartete sie über zwei Jahre.
Wie im Film
musste sie bei einem Einwanderungs-
beamten vorstellig werden.
Sie stellen teils persönliche und
unangenehme Fragen beim Interview.
Der Beamte
war nicht sehr freundlich.
Er wollte z.B. wissen,
ob wir Safer Sex haben, verhüten.
Ich sass dort und dachte:
"Wie bitte?"
Nicht mal Kollegen fragen mich das.
Er fragt das einfach aus dem Nichts.
Schliesslich
glaubte man Fabienne doch,
dass sie der Liebe wegen
in den USA bleiben will.
Wir haben keine Ahnung, was hinter
unseren Rücken geredet wird.
Einmal sagte eine Dame:
"Sie ist sehr jung."
Erinnerst du dich?
Es ist eher selten,
dass diesbezüglich jemand
etwas Schlechtes sagt.
Der Altersunterschied
belastet unseren Alltag nicht.
Nein. Nur, dass ich
auf deine Gesundheit achte.
Ich koche gesund.
Ich möchte,
dass er so lange wie möglich da ist.
New York ist das Zuhause der kleinen
Familie von Eveline und Danny.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
It's done already, why are you
moving that?- It's the wrong way.
This one has a label.
Haben diese schon Etiketten?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
It's other ones
that don't have labels.
Eveline Suter lebt seit Jahren
in dieser Stadt.
Sie ist Schauspielerin und Sängerin.
In der Schweiz wurde sie v.a. durch
ihre Musical-Hauptrollen bekannt.
# Wein' nicht um mich, Argentinien.
# Ich habe dich nie vergessen.
* Applaus *
Evelines neueste Rolle
ist das Muttersein.
Bla bla bla.
Sie wünschte sich
schon immer eine Familie.
Die gilt es jetzt zu beschützen.
Wegen der Corona-Pandemie
wurde das Leben in New Yorker härter
und Eveline
fühlt sich nicht mehr sicher.
Ich gehe schon noch nach draussen,
aber ich bin vorsichtig geworden.
Ich hatte ein paar Erlebnisse,
einmal wurde ich bedroht
mit Finley in der Trage.
Der ging sehr aggressiv
auf mich los.
Er sagte: "I will beat
the fucking shit out of you."
Ich bin sonst
überhaupt nicht ängstlich.
Aber jetzt hat es sich geändert.
Vielleicht hat es damit zu tun,
dass es hier unheimlicher wurde
oder weil ich jetzt Mutter bin
und eher Gefahren sehe,
wahrscheinlich beides.
Hoffentlich können wir uns erholen,
New York und COVID,
das hat uns zugesetzt.
Zusammenpacken.
Die Familie
will zurück in Evelines Heimat.
Sursee soll das neue Zuhause werden.
Von der Weltmetropole
in eine Schweizer Kleinstadt -
klingt nach einem grossen Schritt.
V.a. für Evelines Mann Danny,
Hollywood-Produzent.
Aber er nimmt's gelassen.
Ich bin daran gewöhnt,
an einem neuen Ort anzukommen
und loszulegen.
Schauen wir,
was die Schweiz zu bieten hat.
Man kann nur vollkommen offenbleiben
und es umarmen,
und sagen,
dass das jetzt unser Leben ist.
Wir wünschen uns ein Zuhause,
ein fixes Zuhause.
Das ist nun in der Schweiz
angedacht.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Als Filmproduzent hat Danny Stillman
Kinohits wie "The Bourne Legacy" oder
"Mission Impossible" mitproduziert.
Er ist ein richtiger New Yorker.
Ich bin hier aufgewachsen,
das ist der Park meiner Kindheit.
Die beiden trafen sich das erste Mal
bei einem Casting in der Schweiz.
Es war in einem Warteraum
eines Hotels in Zürich.
Ich musste sie unentwegt anschauen:
Sie war so atemberaubend schön.
Sie hatte ein bezauberndes Lächeln.
Diesen Moment
werde ich nie vergessen.
Es war nicht Liebe
auf den ersten Blick.
Er war verheiratet,
ich kam frisch aus einer Beziehung.
Es war nicht die Romanze:
"Als wir uns das erste Mal sahen."
Es war ein zweiter Anlauf nötig.
Ein paar Jahre später kreuzten sich
ihre Wege in New York nochmals.
Dann sahen wir uns
und dann: bäm.
Zum ersten Mal wieder gesehen.
Ich fragte mich, ob das wirklich
der gleiche Mann ist.
Er hatte ein smirky smile,
stand lachend unten
und wartete auf mich.
Ich dachte: "Okay."
Da hat es mich ziemlich erwischt.
Ich hatte gerade
eine lange Ehe hinter mir.
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Die Trennung
musste ich zuerst verarbeiten.
Und da kommt diese Liebe
in mein Leben.
Ich war vorsichtig.
Ich wollte nichts überstürzen.
Aber von diesem Moment an
waren wir eigentlich unzertrennlich.
Ich war nicht auf der Suche.
Ich war am Anfang
auch sehr skeptisch.
Ich dachte,
es ist eine ganz andere Kultur,
ich bin noch nicht so lange
in Afrika, will ich das wirklich?
Ich war zurückhaltend,
im Gegensatz zu ihm.
Er war proaktiv und davon überzeugt.
* Poppige Klänge *
Ihre Kulturen
sind komplett unterschiedlich,
aber sie haben das gleiche Ziel.
Myriam und Chris möchten heiraten.
Gefällt es dir?
- Ich liebe es.
Mein Land ist einfach nur flach.
Hier ist das Gras immer grün.
Hier ist es auch nicht staubig,
das ist ein grosser Unterschied.
Chris aus Sambia
ist zum ersten Mal in der Schweiz.
Here you can see
traditional swiss clothes.
You're supposed to yodel.
Beide arbeiten für eine
gemeinnützige Organisation in Sambia.
Während den Ferien in der Schweiz
wohnen sie bei Myriams Eltern
im Thurgau.
Sie bereiten ihre Hochzeit vor.
Heutzutage ist es wieder modern,
etwas selbst zu machen.
Aber nicht in Sambia.
"Wieso soll ich meine
Einladungskarten selber machen?"
Würden sie dort sagen.
Ich bin manchmal Perfektionist.
Ich bin so aufgewachsen.
It's taking me so much time.
Mein Vater war Soldat.
Da musste alles seine Ordnung haben.
Das hat mich beeinflusst.
Das ist unsere Einladung
und mehr Informationen
für die Gäste aus der Schweiz.
Sie feiern nicht in dem Dorf,
in dem sie leben,
sondern in der Hauptstadt Lusaka.
In Afrika
ist es bei einer Hochzeit oft so,
dass jeder kommt,
der davon gehört hat,
auch wenn er nicht eingeladen ist.
Wir wollen
kein riesiges Fest veranstalten.
Wir wollen es eher privat halten.
Das war ein Grund,
weshalb wir es nicht bei uns machen.
Auch wegen den Schweizern, damit
sie nicht so weit reisen müssen.
Das ist gut.
Leben wollen die beiden
v.a. in Sambia.
Trotzdem soll Chris auch
einen Bezug zur Schweiz bekommen.
Ich mag es,
dass es hier so ruhig ist.
Ja.
* Vogelzwitschern *
In meinem Land sind die Leute auf
der Strasse, sie tanzen und singen.
Aber ich liebe es hier,
es ist schön hier, so ruhig.
Mir ist es wichtig, dass es ihm
gefällt, auch für die Zukunft.
Wir wissen nicht,
ob wir für immer in Sambia bleiben.
We can head this way.
Das ist unser Haus von hinten
mit den Solarpanels.
So viele Solarpanels.
Ach, hier ist es einfach schön.
- Es gefällt dir?
Ja.
- That's good.
Ich bin so jemand:
Den Weg, den ich kenne,
so macht man es und so ist es.
Jetzt merke ich,
dass es noch einen anderen Weg gibt.
Am Anfang nervt das.
Aber dann
ist es so eine Bereicherung.
Es ist nicht der richtige Weg,
nur weil man es
schon immer so gemacht hat.
Man bekommt eine Weitsicht,
die man vorher nicht hatte
und die man nicht bekommt, wenn man
immer in seinem Land gelebt hat.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Trotzdem möchte Simona über kurz oder
lang wieder zurück in die Schweiz.
Schau,
wie hübsch Mami Ella angezogen hat.
Wow.
Für sein Glück braucht Juan seine
Familie um sich - und seine Autos.
So ein Mini in gross wäre sein Traum.
Für 10'000 Euro könnte er jetzt
einen richtigen kaufen.
Er weiss, dass Simona mit so einem
kleinen Auto nichts anfangen kann.
Aber eine Probefahrt
ist ja nicht verboten.
* Gefühlvolle Swingklänge *
# Let me swing for evermore.
In unserer Beziehung
geht es oft um Kompromisse.
Würde ich das Auto kaufen,
könnte sie Gegenzug
wieder sehr viel von mir verlangen.
# ... downtown.
* Lachen *
Es ist natürlich romantisch,
an einem Sonntag mit einem solchen
Mini durch Italien zu fahren.
Mit der Familie,
aber da fängt das Problem schon an -
wo kommen die Kindersitze hin?
Wo kann man die Kinder
sicher im Mini platzieren?
Dann hört eben bei mir
die Romantik schon wieder auf.
Anderes ist jetzt wichtiger,
als einen Mini zu kaufen.
Ja, wir müssen zuerst
Entscheidungen treffen,
schauen,
was die nähere Zukunft bringt.
Ob wir in Italien
bleiben oder nicht.
Wenn wir unser Nest gefunden haben,
dann kann man über ein Hobbyauto
in der Garage nachdenken.
Garage, gute Idee.
Du musst dir zuerst die Hände
waschen, Ian.- Nein.
Auf den ersten Hügeln der Abruzzen,
Gut 20 km von Modena,
ist das Castello di Montegibbio.
Ideales Ziel
für einen Familien-Sonntagsausflug.
Mich beeindruckt
Simonas und Juans Offenheit.
Sie machen keinen Bogen
um die schwierigen Themen
einer binationalen Beziehung.
Das braucht es wahrscheinlich,
wenn aus der ersten Verliebtheit
ein Leben werden soll,
das für beide passt.
Ich habe mich nicht als die gesehen,
die überall auf der Welt umherreisen
und wohnen könnte.
Ich dachte, ich sei etwas offener.
So hätte ich es gegen aussen
kommuniziert, dass ich das bin.
Das ist eher das Bild,
das man von sich haben möchte.
Ich bin am Ende des Tages
kleinkarierter als gedacht.
Wie hat der Umzug nach Italien
eure Beziehung verändert?
Man wird in der Beziehung
vor andere
und neue Probleme gestellt.
Beide müssen raus
aus der Komfortzone raus.
Es war für beide ein neues Land.
Es ist schwierig,
es entstehen viele Probleme,
die man zusammen durchstehen muss.
Aber das schweisst auch zusammen,
weil man es zusammen geschafft hat.
Man hat nur einander.
Ja, da ist so, man muss sich
aufeinander verlassen können.
Man hat sonst niemanden.
Ich glaube,
es hat uns näher zusammengebracht.
Habt ihr heimlich Schokolade
genascht? Ella!
Nein, nein, doch nicht.
* Ian schreit. *
Welche Jobmöglichkeiten
gäbe es für dich in der Schweiz?
Die Schweiz hat zwar
keine klassische Autoindustrie.
Aber die Schweiz
hat eine grosse Maschinenindustrie.
Dort gibt es Möglichkeiten.
Aber ihr würdet nur
in die Schweiz ziehen,
wenn du dort einen Job hättest,
richtig?
Der Kompromiss ist,
dass wir in die Schweiz
und nicht an einen neuen Ort gehen.
Aber wir gehen nur in die Schweiz,
wenn sich
eine gute Möglichkeit auftut.
Juans Bedingung ist,
dass er nur dann kommt,
wenn er einen Job hat.
Ja, das ist auch nötig,
sonst überleben wir nicht.
Ich kann arbeiten gehen.
Aber es ist für beide klar,
dass er eine berufliche Zukunft
in der Schweiz haben muss,
damit wir starten können.
Obwohl ich es mir
gut vorstellen könnte,
nochmals eine Periode hier zu sein.
Die Kinder sind noch klein.
Vor der Einschulung
müssen wir uns bewusstwerden,
wo wir
unser Nest aufschlagen werden.
Noch haben wir ein Zeitfenster und
esgefällt mir noch gut in Italien.
Es bleibt spannend.
Es bleibt spannend. Es bleibt offen.
# Take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand ...
# Take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand,
# together we will be,
forever you and me, take my hand.
Am Anfang war es hart.
Wie er Emotionen zeigt.
Ist man einmal durchgedrungen,
weiss man,
dass nie etwas gespielt ist.
Er ist immer ehrlich.
Er gibt mir die Sicherheit,
die ich sonst nie hatte.
Und er sieht so gut aus,
mit seinem Bart.
Es ist immer der Bart.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Einen Überraschungsbesuch
zum 60. Geburtstag von ihrer Mutter
machte Noëlle Kaiser
hier im Glarnerland.
Einen Monat lang wollte sie
ihre Liebsten und ihre alte Heimat
noch einmal so richtig geniessen,
bevor sie wieder San Francisco geht.
Doch nun hat die Geschichte
eine dramatische Wende genommen.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen, Susanne.
Ich bin Mona, freut mich sehr.
Hoi, Mona, freut mich, komm herein.
Da ist Noëlle, hoi,
freut mich, euch zu sehen.
Danke, darf ich einfach reinkommen?
- Geh einfach durch.
Vielen Dank.
Was ist genau passiert, Noëlle?
Am Mittwoch war der Pass in der Post
mit einer Absage.
Mein Visum wurde abgelehnt.
Ich war sofort ...
... völlig entsetzt.
Deine Visumsverlängerung
wurde einfach so abgelehnt?- Ja.
Grund ist der travel ban.
J-1-Teacher - mein Visum -
dürfen momentan nicht einreisen.
Hättestdu das wissen müssen?- Nein,
ich habe alles vorher abgeklärt,
ich wäre gar nicht
in die Schweiz geflogen.
Meine Schule sagte,
es sei kein Problem.
Ich habe nur noch geweint.
Das Problem: Noëlle und Matt
sind nicht verheiratet.
Viele andere machen das für
eine sichere Aufenthaltsbewilligung.
Sie wollten das bewusst nicht, es
wäre zu viel Druck für die Beziehung.
Deshalb ging sie erst
nach San Francisco,
als sie eine Stelle
als Kindergärtnerin samt Visum hatte.
Das bedeutete drei Jahre
Fernbeziehung, mit Höhen und Tiefen.
Was braucht es,
damit eine Beziehung
über zwei Länder funktioniert?
Nerven. Viele Nerven.
Bei seiner neuen Ausbildung
fiel er durch die letzte Prüfung.
Das ist ihm so nahegegangen,
dass er mit mir Schluss machte.
Ich war gerade erst hier angekommen.
Ich weiss noch,
das FaceTime-Gespräch ...
Ich meinte, er verarscht mich.
Ich buchte einen Flug
und flog rüber.
Ich wusste,
ich brauche das für mich.
Wenn er nicht mehr will, ist es
okay, aber es muss es mir sagen,
damit ich mein Leben
weiterführen kann.
Er kam, ich hörte ihn
vor der Hotelzimmertüre.
Er kam mit meinem Koffer rein,
den ich noch bei ihm hatte.
Stellte ihn hin, sass aufs Bett und
fragte, über was ich reden möchte.
Ich wurde so wütend
in diesem Moment.
Er brach in Tränen aus und sagte:
"Noëlle, weshalb vergisst
du mich nicht einfach?"
"Warum lebst du nicht dein Leben,
ich bin es nicht wert."
Es war, wie ich gedacht hatte.
Er hatte die Prüfung versaut
und gedacht,
er könne mir nichts bieten,
sei es nicht wert.
Was war deine Antwort? Weshalb
hast du ihn nicht losgelassen?
Ich liebe ihn.
Ich weiss, was wir haben.
Das kommt schon gut.
Es kam dann auch gut.
Beim zweiten Anlauf bestand Matt
die Aufnahmeprüfung
fürs Informatikstudium.
In einem kleinen Haus
über dem Klöntalersee
trifft sich Noëlles ganze Familie.
Die Sorgen
beschäftigen auch ihren Vater.
Was sagst du zu dieser Sache?
Könnt ihr es noch geniessen.
Es ist kein Geniessen,
es ist eher Stress im Moment.
Das Visum, das in der Luft hängt.
Man weiss nicht,
ob sie zurückkann oder nicht.
Wir machen das Beste draus.
Das Beste ist, was Noëlle manchmal
in San Francisco vermisst:
Schweizer Küche und das
geheime Fonduerezept ihres Vaters.
Hast du dir schon gewünscht,
dass nicht beide wegen der Liebe
ins Ausland wären?
Kinder gehören einem eh nie,
das ist ein Geschenk
von weiter oben.
Irgendwann gehen sie.
Wenn man Glück hat,
kommen sie wieder zurück.
Und ob dann die Männer
rüberkommen wollen -
der Hawaiianer und der Kalifornier -
keine Ahnung.
Das weiss ich nicht.
Sie sind natürlich immer willkommen.
Dafür ist die Familie da.
* Er pfeift. *
Achtung heiss!
Achtung.
Hei, ei, ei, du.
Noëlle freute sich so auf die Wochen
bei ihrer Familie in der Schweiz -
aber jetzt liegt über allem
ein Schatten.
Wann und ob sie zurück nach San
Francisco kann, ist völlig ungewiss.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Hi.
- Hi.
Du siehst toll aus.
- Du siehst toll aus.
I like your shirt. You look good.
- Aw, thank you.
Ich weiss,
das ist dein Lieblingsshirt.
Thank you. How are you?
I'm good.
Ich werde gerade ein wenig traurig.
Ich möchte zu dir nach Hause kommen.
I think, he knows you're talking.
Magners merkt, wenn ich weine.
Ja, er spürt, dass du traurig bist.
Mommy's in trouble.
Ich habe Angst,
dass ich alles verliere.
Nein, du wirst uns nicht verlieren.
Me and Magners.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Aufbruch in New York.
Herr im Himmel, segne uns.
Wir danken
dir für unserer wunderbares Kind.
That's it!
Hast du meinen Pass?
Gib mir einen Kuss.
Auf Wiedersehen.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Let me close the door.
Über zehn Jahre
lebte Eveline in New York.
Totale Achterbahngefühle.
Ich bin total happy,
jetzt in die Schweiz zu gehen.
Wohnungen
bedeuten mir immer sehr viel ...
Wenn wir in der Schweiz ankommen,
ist es wieder gut.
Es ist immer dasselbe.
Wurzeln schlagen
und wieder rausziehen.
Die Wurzeln rausziehen,
das ist immer schmerzvoller.
Aber dann können sie wieder wachsen.
There is more.
Tschüss, pass auf dich auf,
danke für alles.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
* Hupen *
* Herzschlag *
Eveline und Danny:
vom Big Apple ab nach Sursee.
Hier treffe ich sie
in der nächste Folge.
Eveline, schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Hi, nice to meet you.
Es ist, als wäre ich
auf einem anderen Planeten.
Im Glarnerland wartet Noëlle
immer noch auf ihr Visum.
Ich durfte den Pass ans ameri-
kanische Konsulat in Bern schicken.
Sie wollten Bankauszüge, Beweise,
dass ich die Miete in den letzten
drei Jahren bezahlt habe.
Wieder zurück in Sambia
sind Chris und Myriam.
Du schaust toll aus.
Die zukünftige Schwiegermutter
gibt ihr Tipps
für ein erfolgreiches Leben.
Eine Frau muss wie eine Viper sein.
# Take my hand,
# together we will be,
forever you and me,
# take my hand.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Michaela Hoss - 2021